hola Yamini hello welcome to mayadeen
the city of eternal spring i'm leonardo
and i'm going to show you some of my
favorite places in colombia second
largest city I love motorcycles so we'll
tour the city on one
[Music]
I will not fish sometimes getting to the
city is complicated I think a motorbike
is the best way to reach your
destination quickly now we're on the
plaza Botero in the center of the city
here you can appreciate these sculptures
by the artist Fernando Botero who was
born in May Edina energy
definitely I mean these sculptures are
definitely unique
like many other things in mayadeen for
example the Metro which runs up here
it's the only Metro in Columbia and it's
been operating since 1995
[Applause]
Ottoman now we're in the 13th district
in the west of the city in the 1980s
this area was very dangerous but
fortunately it's very different today
you made friendly people their street
art and even escalators to improve
mobility for the residents as Italy
ferry this cable way is part of mayor
Dean's metro system it's called the
Metro table and has three lines for that
I'll leave my motorbike here
[Music]
I imagine kima female in addition to a
perfect climate all year round and
plenty of Art and Culture mayadeen has a
great nightlife like here in the El
Poblado district where there are lots of
bars restaurants and discotheques during
the week or at the weekend there's
always something going on here
[Music]
ah Keisha Chaldea I'm ending my day here
I hope you enjoyed my city mayor Dean
has something for everyone
I hope you drop by here one day see you
soon